despite ongoing coveted restrictions
impacting so many businesses
fitness studios continue to pop up
around the valley club pilates in
centennial hills recently opened in the
northwest valley
off of 95 and sky canyon park drive
reporter kate houston shows us how the
studio
is helping that community reach their
fitness goals while staying
safe club pilates opened in sky canyon
just a few weeks ago hoping to give the
community a little bit of physical
and mental relief from the pandemic he
after months of meticulous planning club
pilates opened its doors to the
northwest valley
we didn't want to open until we were
ready to and ready to do so in a safe
way
club pilates owner justin kirkland
requires everyone to wear masks from the
time they enter the studio to the time
they leave
machines are spaced out and disinfected
thoroughly after each class
in addition to in-studio workouts club
pilates is offering private classes
and virtual lessons we don't want to
block anyone out
if they have you know their own feelings
that differ from people that are in the
studio
and we want to keep that connection keep
that bond
despite the challenges of opening a
business during the pandemic
kirkland says it was important to move
forward and offer a space for the
community to safely focus on their
health
physical exercise and health we believe
is you know one of the biggest
supporters of mental and psychological
health which
i think we all can agree at this point
is paramount as the northwest valley
continues to expand and welcome new
homeowners
kirkland notes these kinds of studios
are in high demand
if we can offer someone 45 minutes in a
safe space
to you know exercise and enjoy their
community
a community of like-minded you know
fitness-inspired individuals you know we
want to be able to give that to them
kate houston 8 news now kate thanks for
that in addition to distancing and
disinfecting protocols club pilates
utilizes air purifiers they use
plexiglas barriers to keep staff
and their clients safe now we reached
out to you on twitter asking about the
fitness routine
here come the results have you altered
your fitness routine during the pandemic
you see 56 percent
say they've turned to online workouts 44
percent
say they still go to the gym denise